we're
back at it
what's up reject nation oh my goodness
i know what today is today is where greg
has to amplify his energy to keep up
with this one
ruining the sound waves today that
really
peaked i bet you better work on that in
audio give you a little extra work there
gregory appreciate that alba i know his
last name that's how you know i'm legit
erickson has done a reaction to the
batman trailer
so i thought it'd be fun today if we
watch from emergency awesome the batman
2022 movie set clip which features new
superman easter eggs and a breakdown of
the trailer so tara you excited to learn
more about the batman
sharam shrimps eggs lovelyzer
love easter you used to love it i used
to get candy did you
uh yeah yeah yeah no egg hunting egg
hunting yeah
and i'll tell you i'm professional egg
hunter i'm glad that the peeps are gone
they're no more they can't make them
couldn't make them freezer not gonna
make them for halloween that candy sucks
anyway that's all i got to say
it's gonna be an efficient shoot today
[Music]
the hell welcome back everyone it's
charlie this is going to be my new video
for the batman
oh is that the stunt double behind the
scenes videos that everyone's been
posting the past couple of days
you've probably been seeing it all over
social media instagram tick tock
facebook everywhere there's so many cool
easter eggs so we'll break no
i haven't i have not either
video is a couple days old too we did
see a big superman easter egg on the set
this morning so i'll explain that
what what the channel be sure to
subscribe superman videos of course i'll
be doing bonus videos until the movie
gets here it was delayed again recently
now the movie is coming out march 22nd
2022.
but i'll just number these as we go
along just to stay organized so starting
with the big set videos first
first we have a video of robert
pattinson's batman on top of the clock
tower here the scene was being shot day
for night meaning that they filmed the
scene when there's light outside
but they film it using camera settings
and then post production
to alter the footage making it look cool
how prominent his cape is this just
seems like is that really robert
pattinson hanging off of it
from pretty much all he just looks like
an armless dude
iconic scene brooding looking out over
the city that launches into flight
gliding out over the city
christian bale's batman did it ben
affleck's batman it's a batman thing you
gotta do
a lot the keep itself has always been
used as a big part of the glider
mechanism of all the batman costumes
there's another video entering and
exiting the batcave with catwoman in
their motorcycles
you actually get a much better look at
his costume as well
it looks way more badass up close like
flat butt
uh-huh where's that juice
all the different parts of it but look
at how many gadgets he has
most people are drawing comparisons to
lee bermejo's version of the batman suit
with the way the armor plating looks
nice a lot of people have theories about
what's going on with the batman symbol
it almost looks like he can pull out the
two different pieces the two different
sides of his back symbol and use them as
batarangs to throw at people
and there's the big i only got two
batarangs
to kill his parents most versions of
comic book batman
keep the gun that was used to kill his
parents at various points but there was
actually a story that kevin smith did
for the batman anniversary a little
while ago where he actually melted the
gun down
and used it to make his bat symbol kevin
smith would lose his mind if they wind
up doing that in this movie
most people are looking at his gauntlets
here thinking this is a big court of
owl's easter eggs they look like really
high-end pens
if we're talking about doing new things
that the movies have not done before
court of valves would be one of the
easiest slam dunks for matt reeves to go
to at some point even though the movie
itself seems like it's going for more
they're going to
be in zodiac aesthetic in terms of
references
i'm assuming because it looks like
catwoman is leaving and entering the
batcave with him during these and on
their motorcycles this is much later in
the film after they started to work
together
mostly is that a double that's not her
less than like 25
of the movie and during that it seems
like he's catching her burgling this
rich person's house for the very first
time
it would be funny if this winds up being
wayne manor there was also a version of
a batman story where one of their early
encounters
is him catching her burgling wayne manor
before she knows that he's bruce wayne
and before he knows the catwoman is
selena kyle their motorcycles also look
way more badass up close too
heavily customized and they look like
they're right out of batman the animated
series with this really stylized design
yeah so it just seems like he heavily
customizes all of his vehicles which is
typical
for batman but you do have to remember
the way their costumes look kind of the
pair
down look even though they're very
aggressive looking all this is meant to
look very simplistic
compared to more modern batman movies
that have been the older versions of the
character with much more advanced
technology
this is still batman year two so given
enough time he would also evolve the
same level of technology the same ben
affleck's batman has in his movies
then there's all the set video there and
that was all number five
this all looks like it's happening
around the mirror's funeral we've seen a
lot of trailer footage there where
there's this big attack from the riddler
this is actually what the riddler looks
like during this scene like he's there
in the background
just kind of keeping tabs on everything
while it's all going oh spoilers
it looks like his daily driver which is
a 1963
chevy corvette stinger holy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
matching a lot of different eras so
everything looks kind of old-timey very
gothic even though this is happening
during modern day
speaking of special cars there was also
a modern purple maserati with gold
highlights spotted on the set
no i don't think it belonged to the
joker everything that batman said about
the movie
the joker isn't a huge character in this
first new batman movie
they've been all kinds of rumors this
past year that they'll cast a new joker
for one of the sequels
and there might be some easter eggs for
the joker somewhere during this movie
but apparently according to rumors he
himself is not supposed to appear
on screen during this first movie but it
does exist in this universe
here's a really good picture of a lot of
the main standards damn look at that
colin farrell makeup next to carmine
balcony a lot of people think this is an
indication that they're actually doing a
big catwoman
yeah from the long halloween and
darkness comics
so during those she actually believes
that she's the illegitimate daughter of
carmine falcone
later those comic books wind up
debunking that theory it doesn't wind up
being true her father winds up being
some other person
but for a lot of the story she herself
believes that she is his illegitimate
daughter
you also probably noticed a really big
easter egg for michael keaton's batman
movies
so if you look at the boots that she's
wearing as part of her costume there
she's wearing the exact same boots or
replicas of the boots
that michelle oh how cool
[ __ ] how cool but i wouldn't be
surprised if we spot more easter eggs
from the older batman
maybe even some easter eggs from the
classic adam west batman
a lot of the mise and scent of this
version of gotham the aesthetic looks a
lot like tim burton's batman movie
aesthetic
most of those designs when you talk
about the really iconic designs of that
gothic version of batman
came from anton first usually when
people are talking about the really
mind-blowing designs of gotham they're
talking about his designs
those are such a big deal that they've
actually influenced a lot of the modern
batman films even though each new
director kind of does their own thing
like zack snyder has his own design
language for the way his gotham looks
but a lot of all the new batman movies
borrow a little bit
in some way from anton first especially
the arkham games which most of you
probably played at least a little of
we get a much better look at calling
through damn that makeup
is insane oh my god was
penguin is given his trademark name
mostly because the shape of his face
in his nose make it look like he has a
penguin's face unlike the more
comic boogie version who is also
extremely short and very very fat with
his entire body
resembling the body of a penguin
speaking of tim burton movies by the way
danny devito's penguin literally looked
like a penguin because of his
deformities with the webbed hands and
the way he had to waddle
around like a penguin but this morning
if you heard people talking about
superman
inside the new robert pattinson batman
movies what was happening
is that somebody actually caught
pictures of a group of halloween
party-goers oh
that's it and a very christopher reeve
looking
superman that was misleading
is seriously messing with us from the
set of the movie and they just put one
of these extras
in a superman costume that was missing
i was like what superman would spot her
on saying what's that
they're messing with us or this is just
a halloween party-goer wearing a
halloween costume that looks like
superman's costume
but that means superman existence
actually appearing in the movie
here's the thing when it comes to other
big dc characters that aren't part of
the batman comics like superman
wonder woman aquaman the other justice
league characters everything that
matters
has said the past couple of years has
made it sound like his movie wasn't
supposed to be
directly connected to the dc eu movies
the way that say like james gunn's new
suicide squad movie is connected to
justice league
because for example harley quinn from
the dc eu is in that movie
firmly placing it in the dceu she's
playing the same version of her
character from the first suicide squad
movie from birds of prey
so it's really easy to place that in the
continuity like shazam is meant to be
connected
to justice league because you have henry
cavill's superman
at least it's supposed to be henry
cavill superman in his costume
appearing at the end of that movie but
everyone associated with the new batman
movie say that it's supposed to be doing
its own thing
in its own little bubble of continuity
and that's why everything looks like
it's happening pretty close to present
day like the lincoln navigator in this
crash scene is from the last six to
eight years or so so pretty late model
implying that the movie is taking place
at least somewhere in the 2010s if not
closer to present day
and in the ben affleck justice league
batman timeline
his version of batman would have been in
his late 30s around this time about 10
years older than robert pattinson's
batman
per the timeline of the batman movie you
have to remember that batman donned the
cape and cal around his mid-20s and the
movie is supposed to be batman year two
so this is late twenties batman
don't worry if it sounds confusing matt
reeves is gonna get asked a thousand
questions about where this fits in the
continuity
and potential for future justice league
crossovers when they hit the press tour
because the movie isn't coming out till
march 2022 obviously that's not going to
start until early
2020 it'll get delayed we'll continue
together a long while an easter egg from
behind the scenes a little bit we're
going to try and spot everything and see
if there's anything else that's just as
big as this superman easter egg just
trying to connect it to other big dc
movies
for now though my assumption is without
the addition of the flash
sort of tying everything together with a
multiverse matt reeves is just planning
on building out his own little
batman-centric trilogy of movies with
potential for more spin-offs for other
characters within that
but if you spotted any other big easter
eggs and all these behind the scenes
reset videos and clips or pictures
just write them below in the comments
will you wait for everything click here
for the boys season 3 trailer jensen
ackles is going to be playing a really
big character
and click here to re-watch the batman
trailer a billion more times
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight
and check out tara erickson's reaction
to the batman
yeah a lot of information
a lot of information too much sometimes
i feel like it's too much i'm overloaded
oh i'll lead it i'm actually really
surprised by how much behind the scenes
set
footage we're getting because i feel
like they're way more secretive usually
they're way more on top of it like a lot
of this is
very revealing yeah a lot of this is
very telling too especially when you got
footage
riddler on set right after that car
crash moment
showing that we're probably gonna see
him there at the scene
because i didn't know how that would
play out in the actual movie if that was
okay obviously riddler's doing that
whole car crash
yet at the same time i was like well
will we see him there will he actually
be physically present for it will we cut
to him
but to have paul dano there as reversed
on the stairs
that's really revealing yeah weirdly my
big takeaway
has to be colin farrell's makeup a lot
of times with makeup like that and heavy
prosthetics for actors
so much of that goes towards the
lighting and the shading
of it then to have this set photo that's
in broad daylight just to snip
it from far away if you didn't tell me
that was colin farrell and makeup i
would have thought that was just some
guy
weird looking guy very impressive it's
really really good i wonder if he got
really annoyed and lost his mind like
jim carrey did when he was the grinch
and he had
to be in prosthetics for hours he became
like he
became a smoker again i feel like colin
ferrell might be used to it at this
point
yeah at the same time though i don't
know if that's even harder i mean
to me that's more impressive makeup
because it looks so real yeah you know
it's not this fantastical design it
looks very real and it has that subtle
touch
of just enough to justify the penguin
name
yeah you know like yeah you got a little
bit of but it does make me want to
throw up like when i look to danny's
video
that was pretty cool that they had the
easter eggs for catwoman shoes that were
from uh batman returns because i
i think batman returns has gotten a lot
more respect in recent years
and i think to honor michelle pfeiffer's
in my mind iconic performance
uh is pretty pretty rad unforgettable
unforgettable
also i just want to say that i think
that the reason that they can get behind
the scenes photos do you think it's
because
everyone is messed up so you just show
up you just wander around they can't
tell whether you're like
in with a press badge or not you're like
everybody's in a mess
yeah so it probably would be easy to
just like be around the set
i don't know get get picked yeah there's
so many people
on a set like this yeah because that is
so much thousands
that was i was pretty surprised by how
much footage we were looking at here
yeah blurry as hell
i can understand there's someone way
back in the back with their iphone 9
like
zooming in to try to get a picture but
still i mean they have the superman
easter egg
i wouldn't be surprised if that is just
some
trolling bit of the director putting
someone in costume there or if it is a
halloween thing but at the same time it
raises the question
is superman does he exist
within this batman universe though that
someone is dressing up
as him right here or is superman a comic
character and someone is dressing up as
him for a halloween party i know which
version is it
i really think it's a pa he's trying to
get a little attention he's saying hey
look director over here
i know i'm just a pa but i would love to
be a star so he comes and he
is in the superman costume he's like see
how he hired that day
see how closely i look like superman and
then he got his minute of fame
broke the internet yep i'm glad we're
gonna get one of your classic batman
shots of him
standing on the rooftop how much digital
post altercation must you do
yeah i don't know arms right guys he
looked like a no
armed batman i was like what why does he
look like that did they cgi his arm
like where are they and most of this
footage seems to be of the stuntman of
robert pattinson too yeah and not
him and not her the cars look cool the
cars look sexy
the second it was purple it was like oh
god everyone's going to run their minds
and go that's
joker's car looking at that
moment with uh carmine falcone and
selena kyle and if that is aping from
dark victory and long halloween i think
that would make her character
that much more nuanced in their
portrayals so
so that could be her car that could be
yeah that might be her car
that's what i'm trying to get at this
whole time right now my whole point with
the character development was trying to
link it back to the cars here
what i love about the production design
of this is
it is modern day yet it does have this
sort of nostalgic vibe not not just to
the gothic elements of the comics but
there's something about it that feels a
little throwbacky
towards some of the older renditions of
live-action batman as well so so much
great things are happening here
tara are you excited for this i am super
excited
tara i'm gonna i think i should have the
mic on me
and then put you record it on my phone
and then just sync it up
i think not i think that would be a
really bad
idea the sink the editing for tara
videos is always the most fun of just
lowering everything all right guys
emergency awesome thank you so much for
putting this together hey
check out erickson's youtube channel
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell hit that like button
you're the only one who does that do you
do that on your own channel
nope just yours just here thank you guys
[Music]
you